[Música]
pues es hora de volver a hablar de
economía aquí en directo a América de
France 24 tenemos para ello de nuevo a
Juan Pablo lucumí bienvenido de nuevo a
este estudio acá estamos otra vez y
vamos a actualizar algunas noticias y
vamos primero con América Latina
cerrábamos las noticias con la región
empezamos con la región hay buenos datos
de inflación tanto para México como para
Brasil Que nos dicen estos datos Así es
Rodrigo a ambos les fue bien en términos
generales son buenas noticias como lo
dice usted porque ahora Estamos hablando
de los datos de inflación de la primera
economía América Latina que es Brasil y
la segunda que es México empecemos
hablando precisamente de México porque
el dato de marzo también fue
significativamente menor que el de
Febrero Pues en el tercer mes del año la
inflación de México llegó al 6,85%
interanual desde el 7,62% de febrero y
también tiene esa tendencia pues marcada
hacia la baja en la variación de índice
de precios al consumidor cómo lo podemos
ver en el gráfico ahora la inflación en
Brasil llegó a
4,65% interanual en un dato menor que el
de febrero cuando alcanzó el 5,6% anual
siendo esta la tasa pues la tasa más
baja desde enero de 2021 la verdad que
esa curva realmente es sorprendente
mucho menos de la mitad en un año Así es
totalmente descendente en un año y medio
vamos a seguir hablando de Brasil que no
para de dar noticias y es que Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva el presidente ha
viajado hasta a China allí quiere
desarrollar varios objetivos que tenía
en vista en esta visita al presidente
chillipín a otros también importantes
diplomáticos allá en China de qué se
trata así seguimos hablando como le dice
usted de Brasil la jornada del
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula Silva
comenzó entonces con la juramentación de
la expresidenta de Brasil Dilma roussef
como presidenta del nuevo banco de
desarrollo briggs en Shanghai un cargo
rotatorio que tendrá hasta 2025 el banco
fue creado conjuntamente por Brasil
china Rusia India y Sudáfrica para
servir a las economías emergentes
después de todo el mundo se espera que
Lula también visite un centro de
investigación dirigido por el gigante de
las telecomunicaciones Huawei y luego la
reunión con su homólogo chino el viernes
y se ve que pues para el presidente Lula
da Silva el encuentro es sumamente
importante Pues de una delegación de 200
empresarios brasileños mucho mayor de la
que pues dio en su visita de Washington
y con lo que pretende firmar más de 20
acuerdos bilaterales en agricultura
ganadería tecnologías viajes y turismo
Bueno vamos a hablar precisamente
entonces de la relación comercial entre
estos dos países que desde 2009 hay un
dato importante y es que china es el
principal socio comercial de Brasil Así
es estamos hablando de dos gigantes cada
uno en su región según informes del
gobierno chino en 2022 ese país importó
más de
89.700 millones de dólares en productos
brasileños y exportó cerca de 60.700
millones hacia Brasil lo que fija el
valor comercial de ambos países en 150
mil 400 millones de dólares y desde
luego china sabe lo importante que es
para países como Brasil y muchos más que
le han visitado Durante este último mes
sin duda vamos ahora a cambiar porque el
g7 dijo recientemente que está preparado
para reaccionar si ocurre alguna crisis
financiera global y menos mal Así es
pues afirmemos afirmaron que el grupo de
los siete pues lo que estabas viendo el
escenario de recesión La amenaza de
recesión también de algunos países la
elevada inflación generalizada y el
delicado sistema bancario sobre todo en
Estados Unidos según los ministros de
finanzas de Canadá Francia Alemania
Italia Japón Reino Unido y Estados
Unidos el grupo está listo para tomar
acciones para mantener la estabilidad
Aunque aseguran que el crecimiento
mundial ha demostrado ser más resistente
de lo esperado Se preguntará usted
Cuáles son las esas reacciones Pues
todavía no las conocemos y seguramente
serán difíciles de predecir Pues si
todavía no se conoce pues y no se ha
dado esa hipotética crisis financiera a
la Ellos hablan no y esperemos que no se
dé que no tengamos que conocer esa
reacciones vamos a volver a hablar de
China Juan Pablo ahora de su
macroeconomía hablamos del comercio
exterior del gigante asiático porque el
valor denominado en yuanes de los
intercambios comerciales entre China y
el resto del mundo aumentó un 15,5%
interanual en marzo un dato sorpresivo
porque la mayoría de las principales
pues mercados extranjeros de China como
Estados Unidos y los 27 países de la
Unión Europea elevaron sus tasas de
interés para contener la inflación y
pues Por ende esto supone menos compras
para china pese a este panorama las
exportaciones de China aumentaron un
14,8% respecto al año anterior
recuperándose de una caída del 6,8% en
enero y febrero lo que quiere decir que
la reapertura de China pues parece que
el estado beneficiando en términos
generales pues interesante ver esto
vamos ahora también con Los indicadores
y creo que empezamos en Asia empezamos
en Asia Pero antes tenemos un dato de
Estados Unidos porque el dólar cayó
frente al euro descansando Pues un
máximo el euro alcanzó el máximo de un
año son datos que pues también durante
la jornada están variando ahora sí vamos
para china precisamente Los indicadores
de esa región se movieron medidos por
los datos de exportaciones de China que
acabamos de dar hace unos segundos en
Europa las bolsas siguen operando
motivadas por el dato de inflación de la
primera economía de Europa estamos
hablando de Alemania porque registro en
marzo un 7,4% anual cayendo desde el
8,7% de Febrero Pues Juan Pablo Muchas
gracias por este repaso cerramos en
Europa hasta Europa hasta París nos
vamos con Natalia Ruiz Muchas gracias
mañana con mucho más